[Musique]
il y a tout juste un an bertrand chanot
roi prenait la décision de quitter
touche pas à mon poste
aujourd'hui pour la première fois il
revient dans les bureaux de la société
wallace et retour aux sources je suis
retrouvé tous les copains de la rédac
sait où
oui c'est bertrand chamerois somme elle
émue et comment ça va ma jolie pardon
vous êtes katia bertrand non je suis
désolé de ne pas passer excellent pour
bertrand c'est la douche froide
personne ne semble se souvenir de lui il
décide alors d'aller voir son ancien
patron cyril hanouna
oh mon bébé comment ça va ça renchérit
on ne te voir tu es bon prix et cette
année encore à 100 non je suis content
que te vois à tous mais j'aimerais
personne ne me reconnaît dans les
bureaux commence à personne personne m'a
dit bonjour alors rien enfin sur les
chéris s'il vous plaît or vous expliquer
quelque chose
cette personne qui a fait les beaux
jours de touche pas à mon poste pendant
cinq ans un qui était là tous les soirs
à l'en tête c'est comme ça que vous
préférez la pac il reconnaît alors je
vous demande et où tu voulais et le
faire une ovation à monsieur gérard
louvin
[Applaudissements]
tu vois mon chien tout s'arrange
mais merci ben tu vois aller je
t'embrasse froid ce soir
et tu l'as vu mon cul famille
[Applaudissements]